have you ever wanted a triple-a
big-budget Hot Wheels racing game
well you probably won't get that anytime
soon but for to Horizon three is getting
a new expansion that brings hot wheels
to its track I met and this GameSpot
news update is aching to drive through
some dang loop-de-loops Forza horizon
three hot wheels at sixteen islands that
are all connected by iconic Orange Hot
Wheels tracks these tracks are built out
of intense intersections crazy
corkscrews and wild loop-de-loops that
will probably feel familiar to anyone
who played with Hot Wheels as a kid in
addition to the new tracks players will
be able to drive 10 new cars including a
handful that look like they came
straight from the plastic packaging oh
yeah and there's a dinosaur will keep
you up to date as the new expansion
nears release so if you want all of the
forts and rising 3 news make sure to hit
those like and subscribe buttons
Fortson horizon 3 hot wheels launches on
may 9th for $20 however if you bought
the $35 expansion pass then all you have
to do is wait for its release date the
expansion pass also includes horizon
threes first expansion but if you've had
your fill of racing on the Xbox one then
you can check out some Nintendo racing
action during game spots Mario Kart 8
deluxe tournaments that starts this
Friday at 2 p.m. Pacific
you